I'm not an economist. I'm just an
accountant who stares at numbers for a
living. But the other day, I was
thinking about something that really
made me wonder. If every country's in
debt, who's it all owed to? I [music]
mean, we hear it all the time. The US
owes over $ 38 trillion, Japan owes
trillions, Europe owes trillions, even
countries with oil exports and big
surpluses, they're all in debt. So,
who's it all owed to? Who's sitting at
the top of the money pile? I didn't have
a clear answer, so I started digging.
[music] And the more I looked into it,
the more strange and unsettling it got.
This video is an honest look at how the
system really works and who it's really
serving. Because the truth is, it's not
what you think and it's not what you've
been told.
The global debt illusion.
So, here's what I found out. Every
country on earth is in [music] debt. The
US over 38 trillion. Japan around 9
trillion. The European Union another 14
trillion. [music] Even wealthy
resourcerich countries like Saudi
Arabia, Germany, and China all carry
massive debt in the hundreds of billions
or even trillions of dollars. And that's
where the confusion starts because if
everyone owes, who's the money owed to?
It's not like there's some hidden
kingdom sitting on a mountain of gold
collecting payments from the rest of the
world. The crazy part, most of this debt
isn't owed to some outside power. It's
owed within the system to other
governments, banks, and even back to
ourselves. Let me explain.
When the US government borrows money, it
issues treasury bonds, basically IUS.
Those bonds are bought by banks, pension
funds, insurance companies, mutual
funds, even the Federal Reserve. And
guess who owns most of those? That's
right, Americans. [music]
In fact, about twothirds of US debt is
owed to institutions and investors right
here in the United States. The rest
mostly foreign governments and banks.
Japan holds about 1 trillion. China
holds a little less around 800 billion.
Then you've got places like the UK,
Luxembourg, and Belgium. But here's the
thing, even those countries are in debt,
too. So the system ends up looking like
this weird debt loop. The US owes Japan.
Japan owes someone else. That someone
might owe Europe. Europe owes the IMF.
Developing countries owe Europe. Then
they turn around and they buy US bonds
as reserve. It's like a giant financial
merrygoround. Everyone is holding
someone else's IOU. And the system keeps
going because everyone keeps going
along.
The system was built this way on
purpose.
Here's where it gets even more
interesting. This whole idea of national
debt isn't new. In fact, it goes back
hundreds of years. In 1694, England was
at war with France. They were running
out of gold and the king needed money
fast. So, he made a deal with wealthy
merchants.
Lend me the money now and I'll pay you
back later with interest using future
tax revenue.
That deal became the model for modern
government borrowing. And to manage it,
they created the Bank of England. That
was the beginning of something entirely
new. Governments could now spend money
they didn't have yet. And lenders got
something valuable in return, a promise
backed by the power to tax the people.
That promise became a bond, the backbone
of how modern countries raise money.
Other countries copied the model.
France, the Netherlands, eventually the
United States. That didn't mean failure
anymore. It became a tool, a way to show
economic strength. The ability to borrow
became the ability to rule effectively.
Empires used to take wealth by force.
Now they just borrow it and pay interest
on it forever.
Here's a quote that I found that stuck
with me. It said
debt is how the ones in control of the
system, the ones who designed the
system, create money out of nothing for
themselves and [music] make everyone
else work to pay it back.
Let me know what you think of that in
the comments below. By the way, if you
like this type of content, please do me
a favor. Hitting like and subscribe
really helps out the channel. Thank you.
the debt machine we all live in
today. Debt isn't just a way for
governments to borrow money. It's the
engine that runs the whole financial
system. [music]
When the US needs money, the US Treasury
issues bonds. Those are the IUs we
talked about earlier. Banks, mutual
funds, even regular investors buy those
bonds. Then the Federal Reserve can step
in and buy them, too. And when they do,
they're not using cash from a vault.
They're creating new dollars out of thin
air in exchange for that debt. That's
literally how money is made today. Every
new dollar is backed by someone else's
debt. I know it sounds strange, but
there's really no such thing as
debt-free money in our system anymore.
[music] Every coin, every bill, every
digital dollar, it all started as an IOU
on someone else's balance sheet. And
here's the wildest part. Governments
aren't expected to pay these debts off.
Not now, not ever. They just keep
rolling them over, paying old debt with
new debt, like refinancing a loan over
and over again. In fact, if they ever
did [music] pay it all off, the entire
system would break. Why? Because of that
debt. It's what banks use as collateral.
It's what pension funds depend on. It's
what central banks treat as money
itself. There's a reason US treasuries
are called risk-free assets. [music]
They're not seen as a liability. They're
seen as the safest investment in the
world. So, the goal isn't to eliminate
that. It's to keep it going at a pace
the system can handle. So, you see, it's
not a flaw in the system. It's a feature
that has become a fundamental part of
the system.
control and confidence.
At some point while researching this
topic, I came across a quote. Maybe
you've heard of it. It's often
attributed to one of the Rothschilds,
Nathan Rothschild, to be specific. Now,
whether he actually said it or not, I
don't know, but the message stuck with
me. I care not what puppet is placed
upon the throne of England. The man who
controls the British money supply
controls the British Empire. And I,
Nathan Rothschild, control the British
money supply.
Whether it's accurate or not, it
reflects a truth that feels very real.
Power doesn't always look like power.
It's not always presidents or
parliaments or flags waving in the air.
In our world today, power often hides
behind the scenes, behind monetary
policy, behind debt.
That's what national debt has become.
Not just money owed, but a way to steer
entire countries without ever firing a
shot. Control the debt and you control
the major decisions. Control the
interest rates and you shape what's
possible and what's not. And somewhere
in the middle of all this, I read a
comment that really got to me and it
said, "Sometimes I do think all of this
is made more confusing and convoluted on
purpose just so none of us regular
people actually understand it." And
honestly, that doesn't sound crazy
because if you've ever tried to read a
central bank report or watch a
congressional hearing on the debt
ceiling, it's like it's designed to make
your eyes glaze over. But when you break
it down, it's actually pretty simple.
Debt is being used as a tool of control.
And the more complex a system looks, the
less likely we are to question it. when
confidence breaks.
Now, here's the part that really
matters. This whole system, the
borrowing, the refinancing, the endless
loop of IUS,
it only works because people believe in
it. Governments don't have to pay off
the debt. But [music] they do have to
make people think they can because the
second that belief fades, things can
break. And we've seen it happen. In
2010, Greece hit a wall. Their debt got
so big that investors no longer trusted
they'd ever pay it back. Bond prices
collapsed, interest rates spiked, and
the country was thrown into a full-blown
crisis. Unemployment skyrocketed,
pensions were slashed, lots of people
lost everything. The European Central
Bank and the IMF stepped in with a
bailout. But that came with a price.
massive austerity, tax hikes, spending
cuts, and much pain. For Greece, the
bailout wasn't relief. It was a loss of
control.
Argentina, they've been through this
kind of collapse multiple times. Each
time debt deals are restructured, each
time people pay the price.
Sri Lanka in 2022, they ran out of
foreign currency to pay off their debts.
And within months, the country plunged
into political and economic chaos, which
they are slowly trying to climb their
way out of today. These moments reveal
something important. When confidence
disappears, the whole system breaks
down. That's when new creditors swoop
in, offering stability in the form of
new borrowing in exchange for control,
aka the country's assets. And even after
a collapse, the cycle just resets. Old
debt gets rolled into new loans. New
names appear on the same balance sheet.
The machine keeps going, just with more
control and fewer individual freedoms.
Because this system, it wasn't built for
stability. It was built to keep running
no matter what. So, what do we take away
from all of this? If every nation is in
debt and most of the money is just
cycling through the same institutions,
then maybe the question isn't just who
the debt is owed to. Maybe the real
question is what kind of system are we
living in? And who does it really serve?
We live in a world where debt is no
longer something to be paid off. It's
something to be managed, extended, and
controlled forever. Politicians talk
about fiscal responsibility and
balancing the budget like it's still a
real goal, but deep down they know the
truth. The plan was never to pay it
back. The plan is to keep the world
believing it will be because if that
belief breaks, the whole thing comes
crashing down. And while they say we owe
the debt to ourselves,
that's not really how it works. Interest
payments don't flow equally through
society. They flow upward from workers
and taxpayers to banks, funds, and
institutions.
That's why global debt and global
inequality rise together. The people who
hold the debt make money. Everyone else,
they pay for it. This isn't about left
or right. It's not about conspiracy.
It's about understanding the rules of
the game that we never chose to be a
part of.
I make these videos to help people
understand how the system really works
and how to protect yourself financially,
[music] not with fear, but with clarity,
truth, and a plan. If you want to know
about the shocking money theory behind
America's debt crisis, then you need to
watch this video right up here. Thanks
for watching and see you in the next
video.